[Music]
Christian
I don't
[Music]
know Christian
oh
[Music]
B
hello hi hello welcome to the table so
happy you're here um my name is Rachel I
have two quick save the dates for you
the first one is Sunday May 26th we will
not have service um two times a year we
try to give our um volunteers a break
and uh so that's the first Sunday after
Christmas and during Memorial Day
weekend so we will not be meeting on
Sunday May 26th and the second is we're
going to have a booth at Dallas Pride
this year um the first weekend of June
so if you would like to sign up for a
time slot to volunteer um you can scan
that QR code to join us at Pride so
thank you to Allison Huff for getting
that going so um now kind of to change
our um position of where our hearts are
at right now we are exiting this
man-made Kingdom of um noise and hurry
and
productivity and we are entering into a
kingdom of Stillness and silence and
simplicity
a Sacred Space that we want to enter
into together a space for prayer for
worship for
adoration a space to behold
Jesus revelation of God and heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you and to mend your heart
may we all come
[Music]
home thank you
Rachel sorry I couldn't get my seat
adjusted correctly I just kept
turning we are so glad to have you guys
with us we're going to start off with a
song called Stand in your love and um
this is the
scripture that I think that song was
based on and it was just encouraging me
um today I just had it you know how you
can like on a Bible app you can push
play and it'll read it out loud to you
and I just let it play on
repeat and
um it was just an
encouragement to hear this truth so
let's sink into it together before we
join
in Psalm 46 God is our refuge and our
strength an everpresent help and
trouble therefore we will not fear
though the Earth gives way and the
mountain falls into the heart of the sea
though its Waters Roar and foam and the
mountains Quake with their surging there
is a river whose streams make glad the
city of
God God is within her she will not
fall God will help her at break of
day nations are in uproar kingdoms fall
but the Lord Almighty is with us the god
of Jacob is our
Fortress will you guys stand with us as
we
sing when darkness tries to roll over my
bone
when sorrow comes to seal the joy I
know when Brokenness and pain is all I
know oh I Won't Be
Shaken I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand the chance
when I stand in your love my fear
doesn't stand a chance when I stand in
your love my fear doesn't stand chance
when I stand in your
[Music]
love she no longer has a place to
hide and I am not a captive to the lies
I'm not afraid to leave my past
behind oh I won't be
Shen I won't be
Shen my fear doesn't stand a chance when
I stand in your love my fear does it
stand chance when I stand in your love
my fear doesn't stand chance when I
stand in your
love this
power there's power that can break off
every
chain there's power that can empty out
of
[Music]
grave there resurrection power that
can it's power in your name it's power
in your
[Music]
there power that can break off every
chain there power that can empty out of
[Applause]
GRA there resurrection power that
can power in your name power in your
name my fear doesn't stand a CH
when I stand in your love and my fear
does a chance when I stand your love and
my fear doesn't extend chance when I
stand In Your
Love standing in your
love standing on the rock
[Music]
standing in your
love all right kiddos you guys are
dismissed with your teachers to go to
your classroom so if y'all can line up
at the door over there and wait for your
teachers they will lead you
out thank you Chrissy and Elena and I
know nany's back there and I think
August with our babies in the nursery
Devon and Anna were helping with
checkin so grateful for that
team thank you
guys um as I look out there are several
new faces tonight so we're moving into
what we call prayers of the people and
just to give you a little explanation
for what to expect this is um a
tradition that we participate in that's
kind of been throughout Christian
history and it's a time where we bring
the things that we're carrying heavy on
our heart either a person a name a
situation that's going on and we bring
that out into the light with each other
and we hold that up before God believing
that there are people who want to help
carry our burdens and more than that
there is a God who knows us and sees us
and makes space for our struggles so
we're going to read through this prayer
together out loud if you guys will join
me on the phrases where it says we pray
to you read those with us and then and
we're going to leave space for um you to
name out loud if you would like to a
name or situation that's on your heart
tonight and then we'll close out the
prayer together again at the
end Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and the orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you for the
poor and the oppressed the unemployed
and destitute for prisoners and captives
and all who remember and care for them
we pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender their sexuality race or
other perceived difference we pray to
you for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us and so we lift these names and
situations up to
you Johnny Owen
[Music]
charse for the names and moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence amen
[Music]
you are
not what you have
done or what
has been done to
you you are
something like the Rising Sun can't you
see that you are new
you might
have your father's
name or bear the
shame he left
behind but there's new life
FL through your veins leave some room to
be
surprise cuz you are
new every morning
you are
new Every Morning each day
Resurrection waiting to break
[Music]
through you could
try just for a
to put the
judge back on the
sh oh the
Ling kindness in your heart have live
for
yourself you are
new every
morning you are
new every morning each day of
Resurrection waiting to break
through you think hope is lost but it's
just
underground that BL might be an EMP but
the Fire won't go
out oh the evidence is pointing to the
truth the daily Resurrection is still
Happ
you are
new every
morning you are
new Every Morning each day of
Resurrection waiting to through
you are
[Music]
new you are
new oh you are new
[Music]
yes
God are you hurting and broken
within overwhelmed by the weight of your
sin Jesus is
called have you come to to the end of
yourself do you thirst for a drink from
the
well Jesus is
Calling oh come
to the
altar the father's arms are open white
forgi was brought with
the precious blood of Jesus
[Music]
Christ leave behind your regrets and
mistakes come today there's no reason to
wait Jesus is Calling
bring your sorrows and Tra for
Joy From the Ashes a new life is
born Jesus is
[Music]
Calling oh come to the
altar the father's arms are open wide
forgiveness was bought with the precious
blood of Jesus Christ will come to the
altar the father arms are open white
forgi was B with the precious blood of
Jesus Christ
[Music]
this
BL
oh we come to you Jesus
Oh What A
Savior isn't he
wonderful sing
Hallelujah Christ
[Music]
Isis bow down before
for he is Lord of all sing
Hallelujah Christ is
RIS oh what a
Savor is inde he
wonderful sing Hallelujah
Christ is
R bow down
before
him for he is Lord of all sing
Hallelujah Christ is
RIS sing that again oh what a s
isn't he
wonderful sing
Hallelujah Christ is
R bow down
before
him for he is
Lord sing Hallelujah
Christ is
R oh come to the
altar the father's arms are open wide
forgiveness was brought with the
precious blood of Jesus Christ will come
to
the
altar the father's arms are open wide
forgiveness was bought with the Precious
Blood of Jus
[Music]
Christ with
bear your cross as you wait for the
crown tell the world of the
Treasure You
Found Jesus you are
good what a wonderful savior we have
have come to know in
you that when we are at our
darkest we find your
light when we are at our lowest you are
there with us carrying us through the
valley walking each step beside
[Music]
us God help us help us to Bear our cross
to wait eagerly knowing that you are
good that you will continue to do your
work in us that you will bring about
Redemption and resurrection and hope
help us to hold on to that
God may we be the city with
streams that are
glad would we be the city that will not
fall because he is in her he holds her
up
he is with
us God would you be within
us and would we be different because of
it would we have a hope and a peace that
passes all understanding all situations
all struggle all shame God would you
override it all
[Music]
I thank you for the time to worship
together to say
Allelujah you are good you are Lord over
it
all you are a wonderful
savior we celebrate that together
tonight in Jesus name
amen would you guys turn and maybe greet
someone around you there's several new
faces so maybe introduce yourself and
then Brett will get us started on our
message oh gra and
peace it is uh good to be with you so so
good my name is
Brett uh pronouns he him and um yeah I'm
just glad I'm grateful to be in the
space with you I'm um and yeah I want
and I want to welcome all of you uh that
includes those join us online love y'all
you're not forgotten and um anyone here
tonight um who is new thank you for just
being Among Us I just know um like it
can just be so intimidating there can be
a lot of feelings coming through those
doors just a lot um and so yeah I I just
am grateful for your courage and um your
willingness to kind of step out and come
into a new space new people and you kind
of assume like everyone's best friends
you know and I don't know I don't know
anyone you know so um even though you
know we're all here at varying levels
and some people have been here for three
weeks and others you know for a few
years but um yeah but all that to say
just I just want you to know you're
you're wanted and you're welcome um in
this place so we are in a season in kind
of the cycle of the church right now
that so we just came out of kind of
what's known as the season of lint that
kind of leads up to like this this time
of preparation for the day of the Cross
Good Friday and then out of Easter right
celebrating Christ's Resurrection you
have this season known as Easter tide so
um so we're in this kind of this new
season very celebratory season thus the
music you know is lots of Resurrection
songs and and all that it's in keeping
with the season and uh so the the series
we're in right now is titled practicing
resurrection and we're kind of just
going through the book of Acts and
looking at these little moments where
the early church uh just kind of lived
into what Resurrection Life you know
what it meant for them and then kind of
looking at that and asking the question
okay so that's what it meant for them
this is how God was moving there in the
first century what what might that mean
you know for us in our own day our own
time so um with that in mind the title
of my message tonight is an Ever
widening
mercy and our text is uh the story of
the Ethiopian unic from Acts chapter 8
uh vers 26- 40 so a bit of a lengthy
passage but it's a it's an interesting
story so you can follow um along with me
now an angel of the Lord said to Philip
go south to the road the desert road
that goes down from Jerusalem Gaza so he
started out and on his way he met an
Ethiopian unic an important official in
charge of all the treasury of the
kandake which means Queen of the
Ethiopians this man had gone to
Jerusalem to worship we'll come back to
that later so kind of tune into that
little moment and on his way uh on his
way home he was sitting in his Chariot
reading the book of Isaiah the prophet
the spirit told Phillip go to that
Chariot and stay near it then Philip ran
up to the Chariot and heard the man
reading Isaiah the prophet do you
understand what you are reading Philip
asked how can I he said unless someone
explains it to me so he invited Philip
to come up and sit with him this is the
passage of scripture the unic was
reading he was led like a sheep to the
slaughter and as a lamb before its
sheerer is silent so he did not open his
mouth in his humiliation he was deprived
of Justice who who can speak of his
descendants for his life was taken from
the earth it's a quotation from Isaiah
53: 7 through 8 the unic asked philli
tell me please who is the prophet
talking about himself or someone else
then Philip began with that very passage
of scripture and told him the good news
about Jesus as they traveled along the
road they came to some water and the
unic said look here is water what can
stand in the way of my being baptized
this is like a very eager convert by the
way like he is he's all over it and he
gave orders to stop the Chariot then
both Philip and the unic went down into
the water and Philip baptized him when
they came up out of the water the spirit
of the Lord suddenly took Philip away
and the unic did not see him again but
he went on his way rejoicing Philip
however appeared at aatos and traveled
about preaching the gospel in all the
towns until he reached
cesaria so it's a fascinating story here
here's um I want to start with my kind
of big idea for tonight because I I
imagine I might be 15 or 20 minutes into
this message and y'all might get to a
point where you're like where what
exactly is he getting at so let me just
I'll just I'm the big reveal just from
the here it is it's like this like a bad
movie or something like by the way the
ending you know and I'm just doing that
so um so this is what I'm driving at
scripture has a
trajectory it's it's this Relentless
push for ever greater inclusion it's
this widening of God's mercy and
expansion of God's grace like that's
that's what we're talking about tonight
this this kind of trajectory this
movement uh within the text okay so
let's come back to our story so upon
kind of a first reading of this story I
think what we could possibly hear would
be something like okay it's uh this kind
of interesting story of uh some guy you
know coming to Jesus and he's he got
saved and baptized right there and uh
and so it's a you know it's a cool a
cool story of a of a guy coming to Jesus
you know and okay that's it um but I I
think that would be to kind of miss miss
the point and um and Miss why um even
the
Luke who wrote the Gospel or not the
gospel but who wrote the book of Acts um
kind of included it here so I I think
what that kind of perspective misses is
specifically the who I think that's what
Luke wants us to focus on who was this
man
um because we get a few um
Clues uh so verse 27 right we're told
Philip met an Ethiopian unic and
important official
uh in charge of all the treasury uh of
the kandake um that because he's serving
the the queen of the Ethiopians so this
tells us quite a bit so first right he's
he's Ethiopian so he's not a Jewish
Insider right was not born there in
Israel and spend his days worship at the
temple and such no no he's he's um an
ethnic Outsider he's from the upper n
region of Africa in that time so he's
he's uh an Outsider uh a gentile
Outsider but but seems to have this this
kind of draw toward um at that time kind
of Judaism um which which seems to be
not um kind of unfamiliar in that day
this many people found a certain um
Beauty you might say in uh Judaism and
so he's he's one of these folks right um
so okay so that's first the second thing
though is it says that he's um a unic
right so um this term if you were here
back last June we did um a series titled
Sticks and Stones rethinking the Bible
stance on sexual orientation and gender
uh if you were here for that you know
that this term unic uh in the kind of
Biblical times it was kind of a broad
term so we tend to get kind of in a
certain Lane with it uh a term that was
it was broader it was it could refer to
kind of um like intersex people for
example um and or a more kind of classic
there even androgynous like there's sort
of a number of where because in that
time right it was they knew bodies come
in different ways you know this isn't
like a 21st century agenda or something
you know um even in the ancient world
like they knew bodies come in different
ways and it's not always as simple as
just like well this and that and there's
two option you know they knew it's
different so they had this kind of term
this unic and it was a little bit
broader
term um now we know though from these
other details that he was likely more of
the kind of classic sense of unic
because he's serving right in the uh the
Ethiopian court so this was not
unfamiliar for men who are going to be
serving Royal women to get the cut so to
speak because you know if you know any
well we all know about like kings and
queens and such and we'll just say you
know lineages and all that very
important very important they were all
in you know so uh so people who served
um this is what they underw so maybe
when he was a boy maybe as um a little
bit older but at some point um he he got
the cut and uh and kind of went through
this so um so in short I think like I
think these are the details we should be
kind of attuned to this is where it's
easy to just kind of read the Bible and
fire off you know do my daily scripture
reading from Acts or whatever and I just
kind of move on like oh interesting some
guy came to Jesus you know and we just
kind of move on but it's like w Slow
Down slow down uh these are the details
we should be um attuned
to because um what we have is this right
ethnic
religious um sexual kind of you know an
an outsider in a lot of ways
who very quickly I mean very willy-nilly
just becomes an Insider like he's like I
don't see any reason why I shouldn't be
baptized and Philip's like yeah sounds
great let's do it right here there's
water I mean just like moving along now
uh the thing is there actually
biblically there are a number of reasons
why this precise man should could not
maybe be so Willy nearly baptized and
just fully include I mean kind of
included but uh maybe not fully included
in the people of God uh because there's
there's certain there's there's verses
you know um for example Leviticus 216
through 21 the Lord said to Moses say to
Aaron for the generations to come none
of your descendants who has a defect may
come near to offer the food of his God
no man who has any defect may come near
no man who is blind or lame figured or
deformed no man with a crippled foot or
hand or who is a hunchback or a dwarf or
who has any eye defect or who has
festering or running sordes or damaged
testicles no descendant of Aaron the
priest who has any defect is to come
near to present the food offerings to
the Lord in other words to sacrifice he
has a defect he must not come near to
offer the food of his God now you might
say well that is kind of specific to
priest right the whole Aaron thing the
line of Aaron if you know some of that
Biblical history Aaron was like the sort
of the original priest and then his
whole lineage became like the priests
you know um but Deuteronomy 23:1 is a
little more just puts a little more
straightforwardly and it's not just
priests it says this no one who has been
emasculated by crushing or cutting may
enter the Assembly of the
Lord and that's the end of the verse
just kind
of so in other
words that man
he's the example I mean he's like the
perfect example of
like
no you know just like I'm I'm so sorry
you know you're like I don't see any
reason why I shouldn't be baptized and
Philip you know being a good biblical
Christian should have been like well
Deuteronomy 23:1 my friend is the reason
you know I mean like you can't you just
sorry there's like certain rules and
such you know uh but but but no no
Philip Philip doesn't do that in fact it
is interesting it even says that this
man came back from
worshiping at the temple right which
might kind of seem to contradict what
I'm saying like well he was welcomed
into worship well see that's the thing
um you you might say like back then and
even today you know inclusion has layers
onions have layers inclusion and
Holiness has layers you know and there's
you know yes you're welcomed in and just
like he was kind of wel in sort of you
know and so here's here's kind of how it
it played out uh worshiping at the
temple so what you had at the very heart
very center of the temple you had what
was known as the holy of holies this is
where the spirit of God was thought to
dwell just right right there uh and then
you had this thick this this curtain
this Veil that separated the holy of
holies from everything and everyone else
really the whole world in a way it was
shrouded and only the high priest once
per year after many cleansing cies and
such could um enter into the holy of
holies so that was sort of one layer and
then you had another layer this is where
the priests of God could
Minister uh and then you had kind of
another layer this is where the Jewish
men could go within the temple to
worship sorry ladies so there's kind of
that layer and then you had um down 15
Steps there was which even there's kind
of an elevation thing here you know you
can kind of see where it's not just sort
of forward and backward like you can't
come any closer it's also a kind of high
low effect you know down lower and
farther away from the holy of holies you
know down 15 Steps there there was a
section for Jewish
women and
then way back from
there was was known as the court of the
Gentiles
and that's where folks like this
Ethiopian unic that's where they could
go in fact there was even a uh there was
a wall the the Jewish historian zus
describes the temple in the first
century the time said there was this
wall it was like kind of about five feet
so not impossibly high you know which
maybe makes it a little bit almost a
little more of a heart Pang because you
can kind of most of us could probably
see over it some of you would have to
stand on your tippy toes but like you
know I mean but you could see you know
like in other words the Wall's there but
it's like you can see over you know what
I mean like it's it's right there like
and there's even uh Josephus describes
how there's you these Gates leading to
each level and descriptions of like
basically on pain of death do you cross
this line I mean it's like it's intense
you know and so just imagine like you're
that Ethiopian unic you know and you're
there and you're welcomed and included
and you know what I mean kind of sort of
now I I want to name really quickly as I
don't in any way want this to turn into
kind of some weird anti-semitic thing
you know the truth is this is just the
story of religion in general you know
it's it's just layers and and um these
boundaries and it's like and we start
off I think mostly I'll try to be gentle
you know mostly with a good heart maybe
like we're trying to be faithful to God
or faithful to scripture or faithful to
the way or you know whatever it is but
over time what it becomes are just these
boundaries and these
hindrances you know and uh have have you
ever felt this in the church
perhaps a few of you uh and this of
course goes beyond simply being lgbtq or
you know or trans or something this this
could be you know just uh around male
female um but even beyond that there
could be you know around like money and
certain people like one practice people
will never have is the uh the purchasing
of seats you know where like well the
big TI's get to sit up front you know
like but you can see where this kind of
happens you know you get these weird
vibes and hierarchies and even maybe
there's not like a literal physical
barrier wall you know but it's like it's
it's
invisible but it's
there it's maybe rarely talked about
about about tucked away in the bylaws
somewhere you
know but it's
there and you just you feel it you sense
it but there was a key event that
happened during the crucifixion of Jesus
you remember the moment he's hanging
there on the cross he um he breathes
just before he breathes his last breath
he he he says um into your hands I
commit my spirit remember this moment
into your hands I commit my spirit and
breathe his last breath and then you
remember what happens in the temple
remember the curtain the Veil what
happens it's torn into
two can you see what the image there
it's not just about a strange thing that
happened when Jesus died you know no
it's about the holy of holies it's about
who has access to
God it's about the walls and boundaries
and the barriers that not that God
places that we place and then we pull in
God's name and
and so there that the temple veil is
torn in
two and I think this is where the
Theology of the early church begins to
shift this is why Phillip so willy-nilly
proceeds and baptizes without going back
to the church in Jerusalem like checking
in first you know hey guys we got kind
of a new situation here I'm not sure
what y'all think you know just none of
that he just proceeds
right because the the one who was far
off in Christ has been brought near The
Outsider welcomed as The Insider like
this is not just some liberal agenda
like this in my op this is goes right to
the very heart of the Gospel I mean you
all presumably most of you have like a
non-jewish background like Gentile you
know maybe if few not um but like the
only reason here is because of these
kinds of shifts these kind you be stuck
at in the court of Gentiles you uh but
what happened there's there's a movement
there's a
movement and I think this is the problem
with kind of proof texting and quoting
isolated Bible verses is that it causes
us to miss the forest the big
picture the trajectory
for the trees for the vers right we get
focused on the detail wait Deuteronomy
23:1 says this Leviticus 21 says this
Leviticus 18 says you know what I mean
and we get locked in we're like I got a
Bible verse I got a Bible verse for that
I got a Bible verse for that I got to
and I'm like see that's that's that's
what we're we're
missing we're missing the zoom out the
trajectory the changes that are already
underway and this is why I say scripture
it has this
trajectory this Relentless push for ever
greater inclusion this widening of God's
mercy this expansion of God's
grace so that those you thought by
reading parts of the book those you
thought they' for sure be out not
included actually turns out that yes
indeed they are and in the whole history
of the church is I think in many ways us
catching up to
God it's us catching up to the truth of
who God has always been in this way um
reading scripture interpreting it you
might say that it's uh it's a little bit
like
surfing I must admit here I'm I'm an
outsider I've been born and raised in
Texas I know next to nothing about
surfing maybe some of yall are awesome
about surfing I don't know all I've done
is Boogie boarding which is like the
baby surfing like hold on to the board
and lay on it you know that's that's all
I've done um but I do I do like it
though that is fun I can't imagine being
able to stand out that' be that' be
awesome um but so in my so I must Adit
I'm no expert but what I have one thing
I have learned in my my minimal Boogie
boarding episodes um is like At first
most people struggle with it because we
from Texas we have no sense of
anticipation
like it's just suddenly like oh a good
wave is here too late like if that's
your thing it's too late and this is why
really good Surfers they look crazy
because they're just sitting there on
their board they're just waiting like
they just keep waiting they'll wait for
like 20 minutes they're just waiting
sitting looking scanning and then all of
a sudden and they just turn and you're
looking and you don't see anything
different at all you're just like I just
it's these I don't and then like 10
seconds later they I mean they're
paddling like crazy and sure
enough and just carries them like like
what what did they do right to The
Beginner's eye only sees sort of the
wave when it's here oh big wave right
here you know too late the good Surfer
has that sense of anticipation so the
beginner in scripture
only narrowly focus focuses on the
isolated verses I've got a verse for
this and I've got a verse for that and
I've got a verse for that and I've got
no sense of
trajectory no sense of zoom out no sense
of where is this story going because
then that helps us see not just what did
they do in their day in their time but
it helps us get a feel for the really
key question which is what are we to do
today day in our
time that's the question the church has
to wrestle with just like they did they
had their their own question you know I
mean like it's funny now Gentile
inclusion is not like
edgy you wild Progressive look at you
just playing fast and loose with
scripture you know what I mean because
it's like well 2,000 years water under
the bridge this now it's like just a
given you know like oh turns out
actually Gentiles they can be like real
religious and real good Christians and
they can really follow Jesus it's
impressive you know it is but I mean
there was a day in time where oh my
God oh my God what well if we just start
going down that slippery slope I mean
I'm not joking it's the same it's the
same
thing and that that's where we have to
do our own wrestling our own discernment
to say what are are the waves of the
holy spirit for us today our own day our
own time our own
moment and I'm not saying that's always
super easy or that we'll all agree all
the time on every single Detail no like
there's there's discernment there's
prayer there's
conversation sure all that but but it's
work we have to do it's work we have to
do without kind of shutting down the
conversation say well I got a Bible
verse you because uh we we might be
missing trajectory
there because you see the truth is to
kind of um paraphrase the the late and
wonderful Rachel held Evans um there are
Bible verses for almost any sort of
terrible thing you know you want uh
passages that demean women and children
you can find those you want passages
that are like quite pro-slavery you can
find those you want passages that on
their surface sound incredibly
homophobic sure I'll find you half a
dozen you know
you want ones that speak about how a man
should not wear a woman's clothing right
which comes across as an attack on trans
people I can point you to that one you
want a passage that says men should
never have long hair it's unnatural you
know uh that's in the Bible you know or
that divorced people probably shouldn't
serve in church leadership you know but
you see the thing is the mature
Christian reads with the eyes of the
heart
opened open not just to to what the text
said in isolated verse but what's the
trajectory here what's the reasons
what's the why for that prohibition what
was going on in that day and time that
would make a person write such a thing
what was there under you know and that's
the needed and necessary work that we're
all invited to I'll close with the story
um an example of how this is played out
um Richard Hayes is an esteemed New
Testament Professor um Duke Divinity he
retired a few years ago but he wrote um
a book that
he wrote it 30 years ago was the moral
vision of the New Testament big old
massive tone um and uh very well in it
he argued for a more traditionalist
stance on um what he called you know
homosexuality writing 30 years ago use
that language and uh he said this
writing back then he said homosexuality
one among many tragic signs that we are
broken people he said churches should
not sanction or bless homosexual unions
and uh to this day it's one of the more
popular books and work sites you know by
by more traditionalist folks on that
topic uh but fast forward 30 years and
he just co-authored a book it's coming
out in
September and I haven't read it yet it
doesn't come out or hasn't come out yet
but um there's kind of some press
releases you know he's starting to kind
of get out out there and talk a little
bit about it and he co-authored authored
this with his son Christopher um so I
think we might have a picture of of of
them to show but um apparently he has
completely reversed his position he's
the older the older one as you probably
guessed uh he completely reversed his
position and from what I can tell from
the little Snippets and such I've read
of his story it's less about the
details the oh I I changed my mind about
Romans 1 and that specific verse and how
it maybe means this and that you know I
mean wasn't so much about that what was
it zoom
out see the
trajectory Catch the Wave
see not just what it says but where it's
going and so his new book is titled this
is where I got this language about Mercy
it's titled the widening of God's mercy
sexuality within the biblical
story I I love that language the
widening and widening of God's mercy see
this this is how we begin to learn to
read scripture
rightly because there's a a trajectory a
flow a movement and so I long just I
long for us to a people who like catch
those waves you know that that catch
them that ride them that um catch others
in the midst of it that we can become a
Christ centered um
[Music]
healing community in the world in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen my f my first o Ever After Ser
thank you thank you so
um as we as we come to the the table of
the Lord tonight as we take in the body
of Christ in the bread the blood of
Christ in the wine we come to the one
who tore that temple veil and two don't
we we come to the one who welcomes us us
all of us in all of our strangeness and
you know where we are we're a church of
Misfits myself included you know um and
yet here we are and God says I love you
I've loved you with an everlasting love
since the moment I imagined you like
welcome welcome welcome you know so as
you come forward I just invite you to uh
connect with Christ in that way knowing
that you're welcome with those open arms
so um the way that we'll go about this
tonight is um we'll start with the front
row and they'll just come and kind of
form a cent line right here in the
middle and we'll just go row by row by
row working our way back you can kind of
come from the back and form the line
that way um or sorry actually you can
just come here from out of your row I
don't mean that um I was thinking more
for those folks way over there or there
you can come around um so we practice
what's called an Open Table um meaning
if you're here tonight and you'd like to
participate then you are free to do that
be really weird if I was like only a few
people are welcom to this table and they
like oh my gosh what
[Music]
is um you should know the red is wine
the white is grape juice so uh if that's
a thing for you and um and finally you
can just partake whenever you'd like
some folks like to come here and kneel
at the altar so folks like to partake
right away or return to your seat or no
one will lead you through the exact
moment you know of taking you just kind
of receive and and take in a prayerful
posture whenever you'd like so this is
the table not of the
church but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so
come you who have much faith and you who
have little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long you
who have tried to
follow and you who have failed come come
because it's the Lord Jesus himself who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here come to the table
[Music]
we're going to close out tonight with a
hymn um that feels so appropriate to
what Brett's message was talking about
just the ever evolving inclusivity of
Christ so would you you guys stand with
us as we sing this
[Music]
together for
everyone a place at the
table to everyone BN clean water and
bread a sh shelter a
space a safe place for
growing for everyone born a star
overhead and God will Delight when we
are
creators of justice and
joy
compassion and peace
yes God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
joy Justice and
[Music]
joy for woman and
men a place at the
table revising the
roles to diving the
shares with wisdom and
Grace
dividing the
poers for gender
ders a system that's
fair for gay and for
stray a place at the
table a covenant Shar
oh
weling
space with Grace of gender and
colors for and for
stray a
child of
GRA and God will Delight when we are
creators of justice and joy
compassion and
peace God will Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
[Music]
joy for just and
unjust a place at the table
abuser
abused with need to
forgive in anger and hurt a mindset of
Mercy for just and
unjust a new way to
live and God will Delight when we are
creators of Justice and
joy
compassion and peace yes God will
Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and joy Justice and joy
Justice and
joy Justice and joy Justice and joy
Justice and joy
Justice and
[Music]
joy thank you so much for being with us
tonight um if it's your first time um we
would love for you to either fill out
one of the forms over there or scan the
QR code we'd love to just get to know
you better um answer any questions you
may have like Brett said we're we know
we're misf in some way so any questions
you have about that we'd love to answer
and we just want to say thank you for
being here um if you're in need of
prayer or a hug someone to talk to just
be there for you I'll be here after the
service come find me I'd love to be
there for you however I can um here at
the table we are committed to creating
an inclusive Christ centered community
that touches lives and generosity is a
key component of that so if you'd like
to join us in supporting the work that
we do here I you can scan that QR code
or you can go to the table tx.org
um so now I want to send you into your
week with a
benediction you can hold your hands out
uh in a state of receiving or you can
just open your
heart uh to these
words you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day
and this is true on your worst day so as
you go into your week ahead with it's
yet to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are uh and go filled with God's Holy
Spirit and the desire to extend these
same Gifts of Grace and unconditional
love to everyone you come into contact
with be blessed have a beautiful week
and we hope to see you back next week
thank
[Music]
you God will Delight when we are
creators of justice and
joy
compassion and peace yes God will
Delight when we are
creators of
justice justice and
joy Justice and
Joyce
andice
and Justice and joy
[Music]